so you're going to be setting out your
50 amendments to the article 50 bill now
we certainly don't have time to go
through them all so can you just try and
give us the edited highlights but it's
50 amendments because that's the to give
us saying that we intend to hold the
government to account thats actually
what opposition's are made to before
most of these amendments are the sort of
things that would be spelt in a white
paper that the government has conceded
is going to have a white paper but
bizarrely they say they're not going to
have it till after the vote which is
quite extraordinary if you cast your
mind back to the independence referendum
I published it's got when i published a
670 page white paper but that was before
people voted the government says if you
love a white paper after the impies vote
on invoking article 50 but there are two
very big substantial amendments one is
called the reset amendment that says
look MPs should be in a position at some
point next year or so but they can
either vote on a really bad deal on
negotiations or No Deal I mean that's no
choice whatsoever so should be a reset
to the UK being in the EU and existing
terms so as MPs not vote with a a gun to
their heads and secondly there has to be
agreement with the countries of the
United Kingdom I mean Theresa May when
she became prime minister said she was
looking for an agreed UK position but
she hasn't done that and we have an
amendment which says she won't be able
to invoke Article 50 until she does do
that I want to talk a bit more about
this reset amendment that you are
proposing and which means that the UK
will effectively stay on in the EU if no
deal can be agreed that's effectively
just saying that you're never going to
be able to get a good deal isn't it
because then surely what's in the
interest of the EU to give us a deal
well I don't agree with that see the
problem that Theresa May let's forget
the fact i'm a very strong supporter of
europe and a strong supporter scotland a
look at it from the point of view of a
brexit dear Prime Minister if she
invokes article 50 as she intends to do
without at least an outline of where
she's going to arrive at that she's in a
position that all the EU negotiators
have to do is not agree over the next
two years and then the UK gets the worst
deal of all which is
our aversion to one or trade
organization terms all of the
negotiating power goes into the hands of
the EU and the only reason we've got
this ridiculous 31st of mark's deadline
is because it was something she dreamt
up at the Tory Party conference to try
and hang the Tory party together they're
far far better not to allow yourself to
go into negotiation without at least an
outline of where you're going to get at
the end of the day the thing is though
that some people will look at this
they'll say that the SNP is threatening
50 amendments you're trying to stop
brexit happening you're trying to stop
the democratic process that happens
after the referendum was one well of
course the democratic process you
understand that the SNP pay attention to
the every single local authority area in
the whole of this country of Scotland
voted to remain in the European Union
Carly still you lost the referendum yeah
well Scotland is a nation that's a
country not a county we have national
rights but if Theresa May wants to come
to terms of Scotland as she promised to
do when she said she would have an
agreed position that all she has to do
is accept a compromised position which
has been put forward by Scotland's First
Minister Nicola Sturgeon and allows
Scotland the flexibility of remaining in
the single market place after brexit now
remember we know there's going to be a
special deal for the car industry and
Sunderland to helpfully be a special
deal for Northern Ireland is one for the
Channel Islands is going to have to be
one for Gibraltar you know if it's good
enough for the car industry in
Sunderland and Sheila is good enough for
the nation of Scotland now if none of
your amendments do you get past which is
you know definitely possible the UK
leaves the EU and it leaves a single
market do you feel that a second
Scotland referendum is inevitable and if
so when's it going to happen one senior
SNP this week suggested autumn 2018 is
that that right well if to these army
bulldozes away and says we're not
staying in the signal market will be no
concessions and then says that we would
be any attention to Scotland and and
Scottish jobs and Scottish investment
the first minister said an independence
and renewed independence referendum
becomes very likely and in my view it
should be held within the the two-year
period so Scotland would have the option
of a continuous membership of the EU or
certainly of the european economic area
that would be the sensible logical time
to have it but you're going to have to
choose at some point aren't you because
there's no way that Scotland can be in
the single market of the EU and also be
in the single market of the UK you can
have to make a decision on that at some
point well I don't know ask correct
incidentally if you look at the proposal
Nicola Sturgeon has put forward that
argues that you could be within the
single market place and still be within
the UK customs union and as an exact
analogy for that in Europe at the
present moment between left and stain
and Switzerland let contain and
Switzerland on a monetary union a
customs union a passport union but left
and stainless within the European
Economic Area and the single market
place and Switzerland is not so it's
really a bit rich for unionists to tell
us something can't be done when there's
already walking of examples of exactly
that elsewhere in Europe we just have to
have the political imagination to try
and meet the interests of the Scottish
people and that's the proposal that
Nicola Sturgeon has put forward now I'm
quite Lee's talk to you about Donald
Trump the President of the United States
and I think it's fair to say that you
two haven't always been the best of
friends I think mad alex is the tone
that he likes to describe to speak of
you so what do you make of his first
weeks work in the White House in a
particular of course at this ban on
people entering the u.s. from Muslim
majority countries well perhaps there
should be a moral tale Fortaleza mayor
and i went from according to Donald
Trump the greatest politician in the
world which is how he described me to
metallic destroying Scotland with no
intervening period whatsoever you know
he's a very very difficult person to
stay on good terms with you know there
was a moment yesterday which tested to
these amazed metal when she SAT a stood
with President Erdogan and she was asked
by Sky News I think three times the
crowed to condemn his shameful actions
and the blanket ban and people from
Muslims
it's going to the United States of all
the the Missoulian confusion that's
causing and she refused to do so that
was a shameful moment not just for
Donald Trump I'm in weeks I can't expect
his sort of accidents from him but a
shame for a moment of cowardice from the
UK Prime Minister and it shows just how
much you can go into thrall to such a
person if you've been dealing with them
from a position of weakness as Theresa
Meers and just very briefly and mrs.
Summerton with that in mind do you think
that the offer of a state visit to the
UK for president Trump should now be
withdrawn well I think it's a very bad
idea and I think we shouldn't be rushing
into a headlong relationship with the
the press the United States been quite
clear these first week in office as
indicated that as for the suggestions
from the Trump officer breed this
morning he doesn't want to meet Prince
Charles having there's very few people
come to this country in the state visit
and started aside which members of the
royal family the shell and shan't meet
and that's just an indication of sort of
enormous difficulties you get into when
you hold somebody tight who is
unpredictable who has a range of views
you find unacceptable and the one thing
I can tell you about Donald Trump and
absolutely this is from personal
experience you should never ever ever
negotiate or deal with Donald Trump from
a position of weakness and that is
exactly what Theresa May has been doing